thanks for joining us um I was Eve
stoppen on your presser over there
earlier and I heard you got stumped a
little bit when they asked you about
coming back what was the thought process
there um I don't know I think I think
ultimately just um I have a lot more
left in the tank um you know to give to
the game um you know and I don't think
my kids was ready for me to to quite uh
shut it down just yet and at the same
time they inspire me you know bronnie
and Bryce they they're expiring me every
day the way they playing the game right
now and things of that nature and also
my daughter now she's picked up
volleyball so now she I got another
layer of competition in the house too so
uh it's pretty cool that's awesome
you've accomplished so much on and off
the court I know you're goal oriented so
what's next on the goal list for you um
you know every time I come into a season
my goal has been the same for quite a
while now and that's to ultimately um
you know raise the Larry O Bren trophy
um you know and obviously I know it it
takes time man it's a process and uh one
thing about me I'm willing to put the
work in to try to get to that point you
know and we know it's just it's 30 teams
um you know and there only could be one
winner and it's okay but if you put
yourself in a position to at least
compete and at least just Thrive to to
to have that and and have goals of
setting that then you know you could be
okay with the results so um looking
forward to the season Once Again some
new pieces on the team how do you help
instill that Championship mindset with
the new players um by the work you know
um it's all about the work you know and
um you know I think they'll they'll see
how how I go about my my Approach when
it comes to work and um I think that
would just automatically trickle down to
everybody I'm glad you brought that up
because I was told you organized a nice
little team meeting SL mini camp in San
Diego so what inspired you to do that
and and how did it go um well it went
well uh Stephanie I think what inspired
me one um you know I like I always try
to get the guys together before the
season um you know and then with the new
uh Acquisitions you know being able to
incorporate those guys to the chemistry
to the camaraderie that we've kind of
already instilled from last year with
some of the returning guys that we have
you know um you know self AR ad Bando
DLo uh Max Christie U ruy you know
having you know our core and then
bringing our new guys in to be able to
just let them know that you know it's
all family you know and we we come in
with open arms and um you know and get
some work in you know we was able to you
know get our work in but also just enjoy
being around each other before the you
know the season started so um it was
great to get all the guys together now
coach ham I know you're a fan yeah big
time tell us what it's like when you're
in the huddles with him down the stretch
with a close game with the game that's
well in hand is he the same guy uh
absolutely he is um because and I think
the number one reason why he's the same
guy is because he's been battle tested
not only as a as a coach but also as a
player you know he's uh he's been in the
biggest of biggest games he's won a
championship um as a player he's won a
championship as a coach you know so you
know he's been battle tested so
adversity or close games or whatever the
case may be he's already been there
before mentally and physically so you
know he's the same guy and he's um you
know definitely determined to um you
know lead us to Victory and it's uh
great to be a part of of Before I Let
You Go um Kobe Bryant big day for the
organization in February when you're
going to unveil the new statute your
thoughts on the significance of that for
the city for this team oh I mean it's
only right I mean obviously we know what
what Kobe did for his franchise for 20
years getting drafted in in 96 you know
all the way to the point where you know
he um you know put his shoes up in the
rafters two numbers yeah two numbers in
the rafters 8 and 24 we have Kobe day we
have mama day now like you said in
February we get to unveil that that that
statue outside of uh crypto I was almost
about to say Staples cuz it's almost
kind of it was Staples when Kobe played
but I understand for you get a pass I
understand uh but um but it's only right
you know and uh you know Mamba will live
forever and uh I'm happy to be a part of
his legacy that he was able to instill
not only in his franchise but for the
game of basketball in general